and finally new world Trump fans have to
admit that of all the lies he vomits on
a daily basis the one the one that makes
you look the dumbest is this on day one
we will begin working on an impenetrable
physical tall powerful beautiful
southern border wall you can believe
anything else but give me this one just
admit you got conned when you actually
thought that blob the Builder was going
[Applause]
was going to erect the eighth wonder of
the world for free and Mexico would pick
up the check if you don't want to say it
out loud you can mow it into the corn
come on man we've all been there you
bought weed in the park and when you got
home it was pine needles and oregano
[Applause]
even general Kelly had to admit a couple
of weeks ago the Trump's idea the wall
was uninformed and had evolved who that
pissed Trump off he quickly lights
weeded the wall is the wall that has
never changed or evolved from the first
day I conceived of it yes
conceived he's the Leonardo da Vinci of
walls his drawings of walls and his
notebooks were years ahead of their time
[Applause]
and don't ever confuse it with a fence
Oh during the campaign Trump tweeted to
Jeb Bush it's not a fence Jeb it's a
wall there's a big difference except now
it's offense problem is from fans don't
want a fence or a river or a virtual
barrier they want a [ __ ] wall because
a wall represents an impregnable barrier
that keeps out not just Mexicans but
everything that makes them feel antsy
about the old America that's slipping
away the war it's like one of those
prescription drugs that blocks the
causes of your discomfort yes now
there's Mexican Mexican
lexy GaN has been clinically proven to
reduce the pain caused by foreigners
entering the country illegally lexicon
works with your natural gullibility to
construct a wall that keeps immigrants
from [ __ ] countries out and
good-paying jobs in so you can get back
to cleaning your guns and sending out
facebook memes of Hilary getting hit
with a golf ball except it doesn't work
that way most illegals don't even cross
the border they come here the same way
you came back from Cabo they catch a
flight and then they just stay
[Applause]
like that Australian on your couch
even Trump admitted the wall was bogus
when he was caught on tape and a call to
mexico's president saying the wall is
the least important thing we are talking
about it was always just an applause
line that got out of hand so there you
have it the wall will not help with
employment it's not feasible to build an
even Trump knows it's [ __ ] and if
all that isn't enough to deter you let
me add this Trump stirs you don't need
it because everything that wall
represents the bigotry the racism the
ignorance the paranoia is already in
your heart
[Applause]
yes the wall has been inside you the
whole time
Trump just brought it out because he's
the jackass whisperer but you don't need
it every time you vote for a child
molester because the other choice is a
Democrat the wall is there every time
you feel raged because a voice recording
says for Spanish press to the wall is
there it's there whenever you begin a
Facebook post with I'm not a racist but
and it's there every time a unisex
bathroom makes you hold it to you get
home it's there when snow makes you deny
global warming and it's there at the
ballgame when to gaze on the kiss can
make you throw up in your mouth every
time you use air quotes when you say the
word college the wall is there it's
there when you use jus as a verb
[Applause]
and it's there every time your Tucker
Carlson so you don't need a wall because
you see even without it you're still the
grumpy [ __ ] who ruins Thanksgiving